skank Fest was such a good time
everything about it the fans were great
the crowds were great the shows were
great and like I said the comic hang was
great seeing a bunch of comics that I
don't normally get to hang out with to
have that and have like attentive crowds
it was all people that just love comedy
Die Hard comedy fans they love podcasts
they love stand up they love the
community they know little ins and outs
about it and they they showed up in
droves it was thousands of people from
all walks of life
from all over the country it wasn't even
like there was a lot of locals people
flew into Vegas just for skank Fest to
to watch and enjoy themselves and to
appreciate
the you know the comics and I felt it
everywhere I went so all the comics that
think like I don't know what this is
about I'm telling you put your ego aside
and just think about like comedy fans
and this is a chance to actually be in
front of them and just feel the love it
just was a man I'm just it exceeded all
expectations and even if I had low
expectations it overblown the
Expressions to the point where I'm
talking about in my podcast I'm telling
people like yo even Comics out there if
you had a thing where you were like I
don't know about skank Fest I totally
get it it's called skank Fest right I'm
telling you it's gonna be the time of
your life